[Música]
vamos a las noticias de salud con
Natalia plazas Natalia Buen día para
usted Buenos días Ángela vamos a empezar
esta Crónica con noticias de chile se ha
presentado un aumento de los suicidios
después de la pandemia los hospitales
locales están advirtiendo sobre este
fenómeno cuéntenos si Ángela raíz
justamente de estas advertencias
aprovechamos Este espacio para analizar
un poco como es la situación como han
evolucionado las tasas de suicidio en el
país en los últimos años en Chile
aproximadamente unas 1800 personas
fallecen a causa de los suicidios
anualmente Y tenemos hemos preparado un
gráfico para analizar esta tendencia
desde el año 2010 hasta el año 2019 y lo
que se puede ver en este gráfico
obtenido del Ministerio de salud es que
ha habido un descenso en los suicidios
en los últimos años desde 2010 cuando se
presentaban unos 12 por cada 100.000
habitantes hasta los que se presentaron
por cada 100.000 habitantes en
2019 tenemos que decir también que este
índice estos 10 habitantes por cada 10
suicidios por cada cien mil habitantes
difiere un poco al índice que da el
Banco Mundial para el país que son
justamente nueve suicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes sin embargo esta tasa
sigue siendo mucho más elevada que la de
otros que la del índice promedio de toda
la región de América Latina y el Caribe
que se sitúa alrededor de seis suicidios
por cada 100.000 habitantes
de acuerdo a los recientes datos del
Ministerio de salud los suicidios
durante la pandemia Durante los primeros
años de la pandemia de 2020 a 2021
disminuyeron hasta un 15% en el país sin
embargo como bien decías al principio
Ángela estas estos índices de suicidio
Están volviendo a aumentar y
concretamente los hospitales de algunas
regiones del país que antes registraban
tres casos mensuales están registrando
actualmente hasta tres diarios no se nos
puede olvidar Natalia que en todo caso
durante el tiempo que estuvimos viviendo
en confinamientos era difícil llevar
registro de otros padecimientos aparte
del Coby 19 y pues seguramente esto
puede afectar las cifras ahora También
tenemos que pensar en la post pandemia
no la gente que sigue afectada en sus
emociones en su salud mental por este
evento que vivimos todos tan
desafortunados durante todos estos años
ahora dentro de estas tendencias hay
algunos grupos poblacionales que se ven
más afectados que otros por el suicidio
hablemos de eso bueno Ángela los grupos
que se ven más afectados en este momento
en el país son justamente los hombres
podemos enmarcar esto dentro de una
tendencia global y concretamente los
hombres mayores si repasamos las cifras
que ha publicado en los últimos años el
Ministerio de salud podemos
encontrar concretamente que ha habido
que
las muertes por suicidio en población
adulta en mayores de 60 años y
concretamente en adultos mayores de 80
puede llegar a ser hasta ocho o nueve
veces mayor que las muertes en las
mujeres de por ello
las autoridades de salud también llaman
a la atención de que hay que tener
muchos más cuidados sobre esta población
debido a que el hecho de que ya no
trabajen a que ya no tengan una
actividad diaria y también muchas veces
al abandono de las familias puede hacer
que estas personas mayores acaben
desarrollando problemas de Salud Mental
como la depresión que justamente es una
de las principales causas de
suicidio en el país expertos
llaman justamente esto no a tener más
cuidado sobre esta población también
llaman a
alertan un poco también sobre las los
casos en otros grupos poblacionales por
ejemplo Los Adolescentes o la población
lgbtq más debido a que por ejemplo el
bullying en las escuelas o también
tratos discriminatorios
respecto a algunas poblaciones según sus
géneros también ha provocado que haya
problemas mentales en esas poblaciones y
que también acaben aumentando los
índices de suicidio claro el factor de
discriminación es un tema que seguro
vamos a discutir con nuestro invitado
del día que además va a hablarnos sobre
este tema Precisamente en Chile Pero
además quisiera que para terminar esta
parte del segmento habláramos de lo que
dicen las autoridades de salud a nivel
mundial de Natalia porque Pueden seguir
o piden más bien seguir previniendo y
buscando soluciones para esta
problemática bueno Ángela a nivel
mundial como bien decías pues es una
problemática que también afecta a todas
las regiones del mundo aprovechamos
también para hacer un repaso a las
cifras que indica la OMS para
problemática mundial de acuerdo a la
lente global unos 7.000 suicidios se
producen anualmente y también indica que
por cada suicidio que se produce por lo
menos Unas cuatro personas más llegan a
intentar suicidarse esto aumentan
todavía más las tasas de suicidio a
nivel mundial también recuerda que es la
cuarta causa de muerte entre jóvenes de
15 a 29 años que la mayoría de los
suicidios se dan en hombres como
veníamos avanzando en el caso de chile y
que el 77% se da en países de ingresos
bajos y ingresos medios la OMS también
recuerda que es una problemática que se
puede prevenir que lo importante es
desplegar campañas en los sistemas de
salud nacionales y lo más importante es
hacer seguimiento a los casos que se
detecten con tendencias suicidas y
también prestar mucho apoyo a las
familias claro esto en las palabras pero
pues vamos a ver si le parece cómo se
está llevando esto al hecho o al menos
como lo está intentando chile con
nuestro siguiente invitado del día
[Música]
Y es que efectivamente como decíamos en
Chile nueve de cada cien mil habitantes
aproximadamente sucumben al suicidio en
respuesta a este fenómeno el país lanzó
el programa Quédate la inversión que
hacen es de 2 millones de dólares y
buscan beneficiar a Aproximadamente a un
millón de personas Al menos de manera
directa vamos a conversar sobre este
tema con José Andrés Murillo Él es
presidente de la fundación para la
confianza una de las siete fundaciones
que se han unido para trabajar en la
iniciativa de Quédate Muchas gracias a
usted por estar en directo a América y
quisiera comenzar preguntándole cómo se
ha detectado este aumento de casos desde
la pandemia pero más aún usted A qué le
debe esta disparidad de los datos no
entre lo que reporta oficialmente el
gobierno chileno lo que reporta el Banco
Mundial Y bueno pues lo que ustedes
están viendo en la realidad de la vida
diaria de los chilenos
Sí bueno Muchas gracias por la por la
invitación es importante decir que esta
es una una iniciativa a nivel nacional
en la cual hay hay una necesidad y al
mismo tiempo una una voluntad de trabajo
entre distintas organizaciones de la
sociedad civil y también
el estado porque nos hemos dado cuenta
del aumento pero también de la presencia
permanente muchas veces latente
del de la suicidalidad de la de las
tendencias suicidas que aumentan en
nuestra población especialmente
adolescente nosotros llevamos muchos
años trabajando en con niños niñas y
adolescentes que han sido Víctimas de
distintas formas de adversidad durante
sus primeros años y en ellos aumenta al
doble la tendencia suicida no por eso es
que también llevamos mucho tiempo
trabajando con distintas organizaciones
que trabajan con población lgtbiq más
con con adultos mayores
con niños y niñas Víctimas de de
bullying y también con con familias que
han perdido algún familiar especialmente
niños o jóvenes
víctimas del de la suicidalidad entonces
en en eso si bien cuando uno lo dice así
directamente es es un es el programa que
mayor que más recursos ha invertido en
la prevención y son dos millones de
dólares Si lo pensamos en otros tipos de
inversión es mínimo aún tomando en
cuenta que ha aumentado entre entre la
la cuarta a la segunda causa de
de muerte entre los jóvenes en nuestro
país Entonces estamos hablando de una
situación que no solamente
el morir en eso sino la forma en la cual
han estado viviendo y desplegando su su
vida junto a otros en la cual se hace
insoportable y de la cual nosotros como
comunidad como sociedad tenemos una
responsabilidad y esa responsabilidad
nosotros como una de las organizaciones
que está apoyando y que está generando
acciones en esto Gracias al apoyo
del Estado nosotros queremos intentar
cambiar esta situación entregar una mano
entregar una una presencia para personas
que para las cuales su vida en este en
este mundo les parece tan insoportables
que no es que quieran morir sino que no
quieren seguir viviendo de esa manera y
eso es lo que nosotros queremos cambiar
José Perdón que lo interrumpa pero es
que no tenemos mucho tiempo y nos está
respondiendo todas las preguntas en una
sola intervención está con nosotros
nuestra periodista de salud que es
Natalia plazas Natalia tiene la palabra
José Buenos días queríamos preguntarle
también Cuáles son los Pilares de este
programa Quédate que pueden hacer con
Acciones concretas que las personas
puedan superar esta situación
nosotros queremos
queremos generar
Buscar información en en cada una de las
de las intervenciones nosotros no vamos
a y nosotros llevamos muchos años
trabajando Especialmente con niños niñas
y adolescentes en los cuales nosotros no
entregamos una respuesta sino que juntos
vamos creando una forma de salir porque
Porque no tenemos la posibilidad de una
posesión tan profunda y tan y tan larga
Entonces el nosotros para nosotros los
más importantes es generar juntos una
como a partir de los de los antecedentes
que se que se vayan recabando en esto en
entregar una forma de ir solucionando o
o mostrando una forma distinta no de ver
el de ver el el la situación y es muy
importante que esto es una
en que se levanta la información
primaria y también
secundaria respecto del de lo que está
ocurriendo nosotros vamos a hacer una
intervención directa pero al mismo
tiempo vamos a levantar información del
de aquello que está ocurriendo en
nuestro país para poder cambiar o
intervenir en las en las condiciones que
generan la suicidalidad mire José algo
que nos llama mucho la atención y que
pasa no solamente en Chile sino en
general cuando uno ve índices de
suicidio es que ese comúnmente más
cometido por hombres que por mujeres y
quiero preguntarles si deberíamos ver
este tema a la luz de entender las
masculinidades y lo que es una
masculinidad frágil no una población
masculina a la que no se le ha permitido
culturalmente expresar libremente sus
emociones o expresar humanidad Pues por
la idea que tenemos de lo que es el ser
masculino no Entonces como ustedes
trabajan este tema
Sí para nosotros es importante
comprender que la la que la fragilidad
humana
la vulnerabilidad ha sido en en nuestra
sociedad actualmente nuestra cultura
visto como una especie de falla y sin
embargo es una gran riqueza porque eso
nos permite pedir ayuda y vincularnos en
una comunidad que ve la fragilidad como
un como como una falla como algo de lo
cual avergonzarse como un fracaso la
verdad es que aumenta la especialmente
en la población masculina aumenta la
suicidalidad En cambio cuando nosotros
somos capaces de encontrar la riqueza de
la fragilidad porque eso nos permite
vincularnos pedir apoyo y también apoyar
a los demás por probablemente aumenta
Pero eso eso es más bien desde nosotros
como fundación para la confianza que
somos una de las organizaciones que está
trabajando aquí no y pero pero sí creo
que filosóficamente
sociológica es nuestro enfoque y
nosotros como comunidad humana
debiéramos probablemente desde una
Además desde una ética más cuidadosa
reforzar que la vulnerabilidad es una es
un motivo para vincularnos desde la
desde la ayuda y el cuidado con los
otros Y eso es lo que nosotros queremos
hacer
José otra pregunta que también queríamos
hacerle es muchas veces el suicidio
llega después es de que las personas se
aíslen o que crean que puedan lidiar con
sus problemas psicológicos o mentales
por sí mismos sin recurrir a ayuda en
qué momento desde el programa Quédate se
le puede decir a las personas que en
algún momento tengan
una alguna dolencia mental que recurran
ayuda
A ver cuando las personas ya acuden a
Quédate muchas veces como como tú muy
bien dices las personas llegan al
extremo de querer de quitarse la vida
cuando no ven otra salida no y esto lo
decimos de forma muy clara las personas
no quieren morir las personas no quieren
seguir viviendo o de esa forma no
quieren seguir cargando con el
sufrimiento que ellos tienen Porque
además creen que no existe una otra
forma lo que nosotros queremos hacer
aquí es abrir una una ventana abrir un
canal lanzar una
lanzar un lazo de comunicación no para
que las personas puedan recurrir y ver
que hay otra posibilidad otra forma de
verlo y para eso la comunicación y la
presencia
el rol de los medios de comunicación es
fundamental porque si no como tú bien
dices quedarán aislados y no sabrán que
existe posibilidad aquí el mismo hecho y
esto lo hemos conversado con muchas de
las organizaciones que llevan años al
igual que nosotros trabajando en con
personas en situación de Salud Mental
fragilizada
el aislamiento es una de las de las de
las formas en la cual se va agudizando
el querer desaparecer no y y la
presencia sin embargo de canales de
ayuda hace Exactamente lo contrario Pues
bien Hemos llegado ya al tiempo cumplido
de esta entrevista gracias a ustedes
José Andrés Murillo presidente de la
fundación para la confianza recordamos
nuevamente que es una de las siete
fundaciones que hacen parte de esta
iniciativa Quédate y bien pues a Natalia
para cerrar si bien sabemos que las
cifras son importantes nos enfocamos más
en lo que es la parte humana del
problema y esperando Pues que tengan
mucho éxito
Muchas gracias gracias a usted Natalia
si le parece hacemos una pausa y ya
volvemos con más de directo a América
Hasta mañana Ángela
[Música]